[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a powerful wizard
whose name you've probably heard before
just not in the context of harry potter
and that wizard's name is merlin more
specifically we're going to be
addressing the question
did merlin the most powerful wizard to
have ever lived
attend hogwarts before we get started
it's certainly worth mentioning
that the enigmatic figure known as
merlin has existed for many many years
across many different tales and fables
most notably
merlin is known for his prevalence in
arthurian legend
in which he is associated with king
arthur and the knights of the round
table
the tales surrounding king arthur merlin
and his knights
have been subject to copious adaptations
over the years
but one thing seems to be mostly
consistent across all of them
merlin is a powerful wise sorcerer and a
trusted advisor
of arthur according to legend this
version of merlin is said to be
the son of a noblewoman and an incubus
or demon
and that shortly after merlin's birth he
was baptized and cleansed of his demonic
inheritance
this explains his supernatural powers
but
while merlin was very well established
in arthurian legend
it didn't take long for him to also crop
up in harry potter
for you see merlin the wise and powerful
also existed in the same wizarding world
as voldemort
and harry potter right from the
beginning of the story
we hear mentions of merlin's name in
different contexts
merlin's beard the common wizarding
expression the order of merlin
a wizarding achievement award named
after a society he founded
and even on chocolate frog cards given
merlin's heritage and prevalence in
modern wizarding society
this leaves one big question wide open
did merlin
the most powerful wizard to have ever
lived attend
hogwarts originally founded in the 10th
century
hogwarts has been the home to many
powerful witches and wizards over the
years
and you might not be surprised to hear
that yes merlin
did attend the famous wizarding school
however
it's also worth mentioning that the
merlin from arthurian legend
is said to have existed prior to the
10th century which means that rowling's
version of merlin
came into existence a little later when
merlin actually went to hogwarts it's
unknown
but if i had to theorize i would say
that it was somewhere near the beginning
making him one of the school's first
students
so now that we've established that he
went to the school we need to answer the
next big question on people's minds
which house was he in as it turns out he
was a slytherin
historically merlin has been the source
of much pride for slytherin house
as they were in fact the house that
produced perhaps the most powerful
and definitely the most famous wizard in
history what's interesting about this
however is that historically southern
has been the house most closely
associated
with prejudice towards muggles
particularly in that era
merlin however did not share these same
beliefs and was actually a strong
believer that the muggle and the sitting
worlds
should co-exist while attending the
school merlin proved to be an
exceptionally gifted wizard
particularly in the realm of charms
earning his title
the prince of enchanters this is
supported by merlin's very own
chocolate frog card which was created to
immortalize him after his demise
medieval dates unknown most famous
wizard of all time
sometimes known as the prince of
enchanters part of the court of king
arthur
merlin of course eventually graduated
from hogwarts but did return later in
life to paint his own portrait
which he hung on the walls of the school
did you all know about merlin
let me know in the comments section
below until next time
merlin's beard
you